hey guys Pete here today I'll be
explaining the end of better call Saul
season 5 this video will contain
spoilers for everything that happened in
the series through the episode 5 finale
and everything that happened in Breaking
Bad and El Camino if you haven't watched
the fifth season yet what are you doing
here you should go watch it now because
in my opinion it was the best season a
better call Saul so far and I liked them
all some big things happened this season
Jimmy McGill began practicing law under
the name Saul Goodman and he got married
to his long-term love interest Kim
Wexler he also began working with a
different type of clientele and this is
where things got interesting
Jimmy's legal story being unconnected
from the other Breaking Bad characters
Gus and Mike in the criminal world at
times made things feel like it was two
shows rather than one season five
managed to bring everything together
when Jimmy was recruited to work with
the cartel unfortunately he couldn't
keep his two worlds separate though and
Kim ended up on the cartels radar as
well this all came to a head in season
fives an ultimate episode when Lalo
Salamanca barged into Jimmy and Kim's
apartment looking for answers with Jimmy
still recovering from his harrowing
journey through the desert Kim had to
step in to take charge of the
confrontation and in the end she was
able to get Lalo to leave that set up
the season 5 finale where Kim and Jimmy
had to take stock of their situation and
Gus makes his move to take out the
Salamanca family once and for all so how
did it all turn out and what does it
mean for the rest of the series before
we dive into the ending I just want to
mention that I did a detailed recap of
episode 10 which I'll put a link to at
the top of this video I'm also working
on a season 5 recap for the entire
season so subscribe if you want to check
back for that now let's talk about Jimmy
and Kim's plan and where that title
something unforgivable comes from the
finale of season 5 kicks off immediately
after Lalo leaves the apartment Jimmy
comes clean about what really happened
in the desert and fearing for their
safety Jimmy and Kim leave home to check
into a hotel nearby where they stay for
most of the episode well they don't go
far this is where we see the biggest
development and setting up the final
season when they first arrived
Hotel Jimmy asked his wife if he's bad
for her this sets the stage for what's
to come
Kim says you crossed a line you're not
gonna do it again
Jimmy responds with a yeah but his
expression tells us that he knows he'll
find himself in a situation like this
again Kim goes to the courthouse and
while she's there she runs into Howard
he tells her about the things Jimmy has
done to mess with him after he made the
job offer it's a short interaction but
it's so consequential after hearing
about the bowling balls and prostitutes
Kim laughs in Howard's face this tells
us a few things first that after what
Kim's been through in the last couple of
days she's got bigger things on her mind
second although Howard went about this
in the worst way possible there's some
truth in what he's saying about Jimmy
and he's in a unique position to see it
because he knows Jimmy better than most
people in this story
lastly the way that Kim reacts says that
she is all in on their marriage and
protective of Jimmy if someone tries to
disparage him but also and perhaps more
importantly she has a real problem with
people telling her what she should think
or what she should do while Kim was at
the courthouse Jimmy learns from Mike
that there's a plan in motion to kill
Lalo that night that gives him some
relief but he's still thinking that
maybe he should separate from Kim to
keep her out of danger when she returns
to the room he half-heartedly offers to
leave she quickly sets out to distract
him from this line of thinking pointing
out that they already paid for the hotel
room so they might as well enjoy it over
dinner when she brings up the
conversation at the courthouse to Jimmy
the way Howard approached her with his
concerns far outweighed the substance of
what he was saying this opens the door
for her to throw out the idea of joining
Jimmy and continuing to harass their
former employee they start off
innocently enough but things quickly
escalate they go from using Nair to make
Howard's hair fall out to Kim saying
we'd never do it but what if Howard does
something terrible no I mean really bad
like misconduct you know
misappropriating funds bribing witnesses
something like that we watch as Kim
moves past we'd never do it but and we
see her get to the idea that we could
pull this off she expresses the good she
thinks she can do with the two million
dollars they stand to collect
from the Sandpiper settlement she paints
a picture of a scenario where everyone
wins except of course Howard and she
minimizes the downside by saying it
would be just a career setback from one
lawyer her plan is to open a pro bono
Law Center so people with limited means
can get the same kind of representation
that millionaires get Jimmy tries to
stop the plans momentum by pointing out
that what she's suggesting goes far
beyond scamming someone at a bar he
tells her it would take Howard doing
something unforgivable to get the other
lawyers to turn on him he goes as far as
saying that this scorched earth strategy
is not Kim it's not who she is and that
she wouldn't be okay with it not in the
cold light of day as viewers everything
Jimmy is saying tracks with what we know
about Kim Wexler right up to the point
where she looks him in the eye and says
wouldn't I wouldn't she be okay with it
she looks dead serious and the question
changes from would Kim really do
something like this - Howard - has Kim
done something like this before we don't
know because we don't really know about
her background she gets up to take a
shower and she tops the whole thing off
by turning to Jimmy and making the
finger guns that we saw him do at the
end of season four as far as we can tell
she's all in for this and she's ready
for whatever's to come Jimmy on the
other hand looks like he is
uncomfortable he looks lost and alone
and it's a mirror image of the way Kim
looked when he told her he was going to
start practicing assault Goodman going
into the season five finale we had three
characters whose fates were unknown Kim
Lalo and nacho Varga nacho was the most
likely candidate to become a casualty
since he's been stuck in the role of
playing both sides in the cartel cold
war he worked his way up in the solemn
unka family organization but when he
made a move to get out from under his
boss Hector Gus fring found out and
compromised him nachos plan was to get
out of the drug business and in doing
that he would protect his father who has
no connection to his criminal activity
Gus had other plans and won't let go of
his asset even when Mike encourages him
to do so after getting bailed out of
jail and his visit to Kim and Jimmy's
Lalo instructs nacho to take him to
Mexico they arrived at his
well-protected Hacienda and
where Gus plans to move forward with his
assassination attempt not to a place as
part and goes along with things and even
manages to impress Don Eladio
when Lalo takes him to meet the cartel
boss the assassins eventually make
contact and instruct nacho to leave the
back gate open he manages that after
creating a diversion and then slips out
the door to freedom from the compound at
least it's too early to tell what that
will mean under the threat of violence
against his father he betrayed one boss
to serve the other he managed to survive
the season but he finds himself in a
really difficult situation because the
boss he served didn't succeed in his
plan to take out the other one
it wasn't from a lack of planning either
and don't forget just how much Gus and
Mike had to do to get to the point where
they could make a move on Lalo south of
the border Gus fring is a man who knows
how to get things done and for all
intents and purposes his plan was not
the problem according to the showrunner
Peter Gould the one thing Gus nacho and
Mike weren't counting on is that Lalo is
tricky he's lucky he's smart and he's
able to triumph against incredible odds
and that's what he does he triumphs with
some quick thinking and a plan to use
his escape tunnel as a trap for his
attackers Lalo manages to make it out of
the season alive after the gun battle is
over Lalo uses the one assassin who
hasn't died yet to call the man who
hired him he tells him that was a
middleman but Lalo isn't worried about
that because he says he knows who
actually hired him the call is placed so
the middleman will report to Gus that
Lalo has been killed which should buy
him a little time to plan his next move
Lalo notices that nacho isn't around and
when he looks at the decanter that tells
us that he suspects nacho was involved
in the attack the season ends with Lalo
walking away from Hacienda into the
darkness after seeing the dead body of
his cook his home has been attacked
he's been betrayed by the man who he was
entrusting to run his family business in
the US and we can imagine that his
number one priority will be revenge at
the end of better call Saul season 5
Jimmy and Kim are still together Lalo
and nacho are both still alive
and Gus is somewhat exposed after his
failed assassination attempt Kim has a
plan to go after Howard and even
though he probably should try to stop
her I think we can expect Jimmy to go
along with it these two have come a long
way since the first episode of the
season in that Kim is trying to slow
down Jimmy's plans to practice AI Saul
Goodman he throws out the idea of
offering a 50% off deal to potential new
clients and she gets him to reconsider
he even says see this is why this works
I go too far and you pull me back by the
end things are turned the other way
around and Jimmy is the one who wants to
slow Kim down we can imagine that he
won't be able to change her course any
more than she was able to change his
they haven't exactly switched places but
he evolved alongside each other based on
their circumstances when Jimmy crossed
the line the first time by surprising
her at the Mesa Verde meeting she
decided to double down on the
relationship and get married this in her
turn at the end leaves us heading into
the final season wondering what's really
going on with Kim I discussed that and
other questions going into season six in
my questions video I put out last week
so if you want to join the conversation
about Kim and where she's heading you
should check out that video for now it's
a cliffhanger as to where her plan to
take down Howard in order to get the
Sandpiper settlement done is coming from
nachos in Mexico where Lalo will
probably like to have a word with him
Gus has been reluctant to help him under
normal circumstances so Mike will
probably have to make that happen
if nacho is able to get away Lalo will
be out to settle the score and exact his
revenge against Gus and his plans will
probably include Jimmy since he came
through with the bail money when he
needed him to Jimmy may still have to
deal with the lingering effects of his
PTSD and his buried feelings about his
brother Chuck's death while he took a
few steps back at the end of the season
everything is still in place for him to
become the Saul Goodman we know from
Breaking Bad but it does seem likely
that something will have to come up to
take Kim out of the picture before that
happens there's only one season a better
call Saul to come it will be 13 episodes
and we'll find out what happens between
Jimmy and Kim what happens with Lalo and
nacho and how Jimmy fully embraces this
persona of Saul Goodman that we know
from Breaking Bad and with that I'll
leave it there let me know in the
comments what
think's gonna happen in the next season
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon